blé fédéral et tu aujourd'hui une
tradition et la réunion d'aujourd'hui en
est une confirmation je vous remercie de
m'avoir invité à me
prononcer ici devant vous et je
m'arrêterai aux questions sur la
pression au plus haut point la position
des sénateurs de la fédération de russie
sur l'ordre du jour et sur le fait
qu'ils sont sur prêts à contribuer à la
défense des intérêts de la russie sur
l'arène internationale dans le contexte
des échanges parlementaires
internationaux nous accordons une grande
importance à la coopération au niveau
des chambres et des comités pour le
renforcement de nos positions à
l'international
les diplomates ont besoin de ressentir
le soutien de la communauté nationale
c'est important au niveau international
aussi et de façon à pouvoir avoir des
conditions les plus favorables possibles
pour le développement beau et très poli
j'ai amélioré la prospérité et l'élevage
et la population
au cours commencent à vanier après les
crises du pouce et mais j'irai faire un
peignage des préjudices bien
mener
notamment en matière de défense des
intérêts de souveraineté nationale et de
maintien de la vérité historique
le 18 novembre dernier le président
poutine avait donné son appréciation sur
les grandes orientations de notre
politique diplomatique mais il nous
avait aussi fixé des objectifs à
l'international difficile de dire que la
situation est stable ce n'est pas du
tout le cas dans notre dans notre monde
actuellement et les eaux les actions de
washington et de ses alliés occidentaux
ne font que rendre plus difficile la
situation et nous avons donc des
décisions à prendre ici
face à l'utilisation de l'instrument
illégitime tels que les sanctions et
d'ingérence dans les politiques
intérieures et d'ailleurs les pays
occidentaux détruisent sciemment les
systèmes d'architecturé de paix de
maintien de la paix de la sécurité à
l'international qui avait hérité de la
deuxième guerre mondiale
et ces nouvelles règles du jeu qu'ils
installent qu'ils instaurent et qui sont
qui correspondent à des formats pratique
pour les pays occidentaux sont imposés
aux autres pays et ses projecteurs qui
s'imposent de la part des pays
occidentaux
notamment en ville y aura une donc une
réponse une rencontre qui se fera les 9
et 10 décembre prochain
et en cela après quand on voit les
bombardements qui ont été faits en irak
en libye en yougoslavie et les
expérimentations qui ont été faites en
afghanistan se demande comment les pays
occidentaux ne peuvent se permettre de
donner des critères de démocratie à
d'autres pays est ce cette nouvelle
politique
ce qui
ne fait que renforcer de la
confrontation entre les groupes de pays
est un préjudice important
donc aujourd'hui il ne peut y avoir
d'autre alternative que
je suivre cette politique
que la fédération de russie s'est défini
pour elle-même c'est-à-dire de n'imposer
aucune
solution de l'extérieur mais avant tout
se conformer aux règles de l'onu et nous
mettons court à toute tentative de
discuter avec nous sur un ton arrogant
d'exercer un chantage contre nous et
d'agir sur la situation intérieure en
russie les discussions avec tout
interlocuteur ne peuvent se faire que
sur la base d'un respect mutuel et la
recherche de compromis cette ligne et
cette défense cohérente des intérêts de
la russie et dans nos relations avec nos
partenaires sur toutes les orientations
de la diplomatie montre que cela peut
être efficace cette coopération se fait
avec la plupart des pays qui
représentent encore plus de 80% de la
population de la planète la russie est
une grande puissance européenne
asiatique eurasiatique et pacifique et
elle a conscience de sa responsabilité
importante en matière de maintien de la
paix de la stabilité sur la planète et
nous proposons une politique qui
consiste à unir nos efforts à mobiliser
les efforts collectifs pour résoudre les
questions qui se posent aujourd'hui en
matière de terrorisme de pandémies comme
les virus et d'autres défis et c'est
cette philosophie qui est à la base de
la doctrine énoncé par le président
poutine lors des différentes plateformes
internationales
il s'agit pas ici de former un club
d'élus d'autant plus que
la condition aujourd'hui de
développement sont particulières dans le
monde mais c'est un travail de pour un
travail poursuivi qui est fait en
matière de développement des initiatives
qui peuvent être manifestée cela se
manifeste notamment au niveau du brics
de traiter de shanghai 2
et les décisions sont prises sur la base
d'un consensus
il ya une structure comme le g20 par
exemple ou des discussions importantes
en matière économique et sociale sont
discutées et on retrouve un petit peu
les représentants des pays du g7 et les
pays des brics
sur dans l'espace dans le vaste espace
eurasiatique
les unions les organisations qui ont été
mises en place telles que la série
l'état de l'union entre la russie la
biélorussie et le tc l'organisation de
chambre le chambre de shanghai tous ces
processus en eurasie montre l'importante
de la l'alliance stratégique entre la
russie et la chine et cela un rôle très
important en matière de stabilisation
sur le continent
il ya statut de partenariat stratégique
privilégié avec l'inde et dans la région
asie pacifique notamment autour de la
zone la séan est toute à sa coopération
avec ces acteurs notamment avec la chine
dans le cadre de
la nouvelle orientation une voix une
route et tout cela fait partie des
initiatives que nous développons sur
notre grand continent sous là permettent
de réaliser
l'orientation définie par le président
poutine en matière de
pas seulement de développement durable
mais aussi de mise en place d'un contour
de sécurité et de défense d'un
territoire un et indivisible
il ya cette politique que nous faisons
que nous menons en afrique après le
premier sommet russie afrique avait
organisé en octobre 2019 et avec nos
amis africains nous préparons donc une
deuxième rencontre dans le même format
et nous travaillons aussi avec les
structures sous régionales et régionales
notre pays parte apporter un une
contribution importante dans la
décolonisation et se tient tient à ce
principe de non-ingérence
des contre les tentatives des anciennes
colonies les anciennes métropoles qui
cherchent à imposer à leurs colonies
leur objectif
chaque pays chaque peuple a le droit de
déterminer son mode de développement
la tension est porté aussi sur la
nécessité de surmonter tous les conflits
dans la région et le règlement de toutes
ces situations
de conflit la vaincre le terrorisme
notamment ceux là se manifester aussi
dans les négociations sur le nagorny
karabakh entre eux
l'azerbaïdjan et l'arménie nous
travaillons dans la même optique en
libye en afghanistan et sur la question
du conflit israélo-palestinien et
d'autres points chauds et aussi sur la
péninsule coréenne
la position sur l'ukraine est toujours
clair il faut surmonter
la crise intérieure uniquement dans le
respect des accords de minsk qui a été
validé par une décision du conseil de
sécurité de l'onu et qui correspond au
droit international
le gage de succès c'est la discussion
entre kiev et logan skate donetsk
les efforts de médiation qui ont sont
faits dans le cadre du
dialogue de du format normandie on voit
ici l'ingérence des pays de l'otan qui
cherche à transformer ce
se promènent ce problème en rhétorique
antirusse
on voit un certain nombre de manoeuvres
provocatrice des forces américaines tant
sur terre que sur mer et dans les airs
et ils se permettent de juger de la
façon dont la russie dispose de ses
troupes sur son propre territoire
nous souhaitons de garantie à long terme
et nous préparons donc une initiative
c'est à dire que à chaque
acte hostile nous répondrons par un acte
qui corresponde à la défense de nos
intérêts et 7
ce renforcement de la rhétorique
russophobe se manifeste
sur dans différents domaines dont le
passage vers
et un certain nombre d'autres
politique
nous cherchons sous l'égide de l'onu à
mettre cour a coupé court à toutes les
initiatives
occidentale d'utiliser les différentes
formes de protectionnisme et de les
imposer au pays
via un accord universel de ti doit être
respectée ici qui consiste à la non
prolifération des armes nucléaires
biologiques et chimiques
cela fait partie des priorités et de
défense des citoyens russes dans le
monde la défense de la culture russe de
du système d'enseignement russe et de sa
culture nous continuerons à travailler
avec les différentes structures
régionales
notamment
le conseil des sujets de la fédération
auprès de notre ministère a émis dont un
certain nombre de recommandations qui
ont été approuvés cette politique a
montré son efficacité
notamment dans son activité avec les
partenaires internationaux
chers collègues
en agissant de façon prévisible la
russie travaille avec c
partenaires et ses interlocuteurs dans
un objet dans un objectif tout à fait
respectable et qui prennent qui tiennent
en compte qui tiennent compte des
résultats de la deuxième guerre mondiale
et nous allons continuer à travailler à
la démocratisation des relations
internationales en confirmant l'intérêt
que nous avons pour une coopération
étroite avec
les organes législatifs de la russie
dans le cadre de ce qu'on appelle la
diplomatie parlementaire et sur ordre du
président une commission du parti russie
unie a été mise en place pour le soutien
de cette activité parlementaire et d'ici
la fin décembre nous aurons notre
première réunion en ce sens je vous
remercie pour votre attention
merci
comme tout joueur professionnel
mais c'est clair je veux remercier
encore une fois mettant pas sa question
chère celle interne dames messieurs
si vous voulez poser des questions
prendre parole je vous demande de me
faire signer nous passons aux questions
l'adie myrdhin guînes à vos paroles je
vais revenir si madame ateliers en cause
la position du ministère des affaires
étrangères pour à la question
d'interdire à
l'élection des droites des compatriotes
des ressortissants russo kazakh astana a
car guy 10 et 11 bis à qui notre
position vis-à-vis de la tolérance pour
des raisons ethniques
que ce soit tel ou tel peuple elle est
universelle et nous acceptons aucune
manifestation de ce type à l'égard de
qui que ce soit et en particulier de nos
compatriotes qui sont présents dans les
autres pays le racisme le chauvinisme et
d'autres formes de sanofi sont
inacceptables où que ce soit la russie
est initiatrice traditionnement de plus
de 50 résolution par an dans au sein de
l'onu contre l'héroïsation des héros du
nazisme etc et cela est inacceptable et
ces résolutions sont de plus en plus
soutenue curieusement l'union européenne
se maintient pour des raisons
liées à le cren et elle considère que
tout appel a condamné les manifestations
du racisme du sionisme sont selon les
pays occidentaux une atteinte à la
liberté de parole je comprends que la
liberté de parole ne peut être
justifiée parcours rien du tout si elle
se manifeste dans cette optique mais en
tout cas tous les membres de cette
organisation internationale
ont adopté les décisions du tribunal de
nuremberg mais malheureusement l'union
européenne à août deux défendent
recettes à libérer de cette liberté de
parole et elle oriente cette politique
de façon à ce que dans certains pays
les
criminels nazis soient
héroïsé soient considérés comme des
héros en ce qui concerne l'espace de la
séville et nous avons un mécanisme
spécial dans le cadre de la communauté
qui a été mise en place et qui examine
ces questions est aujourd'hui pour lui
attribuer plus d'importance notamment
dans ces cas même si ce sont des cas
isolés mais qui en tout cas qui
manifeste un problème systémique nous
avons attiré l'attention sur le fait que
le statut de la séville
doit proclamer
une commission sur les droits
des droits de l'homme nous avons attiré
l'attention de nos partenaires dans la
communauté il ya un an et demi et il y à
cet accord et j'espère que prochainement
nous pourrons
voir ça de façon plus concrète jeu je le
remercie peter thomas f s'il vous plaît
mais sera la drogue la pandémie de la
cornée virus a apporté des modifications
considérables le format approprié des
projets internationaux dans le domaine
culturel
d'après les diplomates russes
quelles sont les réalités opportune et
les particularités des perspectives de
la coopération culturelle et notamment
l'organisation des années croisées de la
culture bien sûr l'infection à cause
d'un virus a affecté tous les types de
contacts explose niveau culturel et
peut-être surtout au niveau culturel
c'est à dire que les grandes de
manifestations que nous avions
habituellement traditionnellement avec
des visites des tournées dans les pays
les uns des autres mais je dirais que
aucune année croisée n'a été annulé en
tout cas nous avons reporté à six mois
parfois nous avons
mis ces manifestations sous forme de
visioconférence mais en tout cas nous
avons cherché à maintenir les rencontres
en présentiel sottom c'est possible et
nous sommes attachés à cette forme
d'action elle est importante parce que
cette coopération permet au pays et la
diplomatie de la culture de travailler
ensemble et chez nous c'est un argument
évidemment très fort dans notre action à
l'international et
ses années croisées et d'autres types de
manifestations
culturelles que ce soit des festivals
des festivals de cinéma da tout cela ce
sont des programmes et je pense que vous
avez des informations sur les
manifestations qui sont prévues mais
tout cela va être mise en oeuvre sans
aucun d'eux bien entendu la pandémie a
eu un impact pas seulement dans le
domaine culturel mais si au niveau
d'autres contacts entre les états entre
les gouvernements et elle a montré que
bien souvent
ici on revient dans les normes
habituelles de la vie on peut utiliser
les nouvelles ressources internet qu'ils
font et qui permettent justement de
compléter les contacts entre quatre yeux
et je pense que même sans décision
spécifique ces nouvelles formes de
discussions se sont utilisés et votre
humble
serviteur aujourd'hui ce va participer à
la rencontre de leurs essais
ce vol il y aura des représentants en
présentiel c'est à dire quand en plus de
la préparation de ces rencontres
habituelles il y aura de façon plus
efficace justement les nouvelles formes
de communication je vous remercie
sénateurs pour les tailles s'il vous
plaît je les remercie madame athénienne
kosséré victory bonjour les relations
entre la russie et la turquie sont
toujours au centre de nos intérêts nous
voyons que la turquie cette activité est
réalisée politique active sur le
territoire des pays de l'ex urss
d'où vient ma question est ce que la
livraison des drones la baraque a fait
part à la turquie a le cren démontre que
la turquie commence à jouer le rôle
négatif à quant à la résolution du
conflit camion oui la turquie ce n'est
pas un secret travaille activement dans
les territoires limitrophes et pas
seulement mais même dans des espaces
plus éloignées nous respectons le droit
de chaque pays d'utiliser
ses possibilités ses opportunités pour
défendre les intérêts leurs intérêts et
travailler de façon plus ou moins
rapproché sur notamment s'il ya des
compatriotes sur place et nous aussi
nous travaillons de la même façon mais
s'il ya une seule question toutes ces
actions de ce type
de la part de chaque état doivent être
légitime c'est-à-dire doivent être les à
la promotion des intérêts légitimes
et c'est à mon avis un axiome que nos
partenaires sûrs que ne contestent pas
dans l'espace postsoviétique
effectivement la turquie est très
efficace très active dans l'espace de
l'asie centrale par exemple tous les
pays qui font partie des peuples turcs
foule turcophones d'ailleurs voulait
représenter mai
c'est un de mes coins préférés de la
fédération de russie la turquie
travaille aussi avec les pays du caucase
du sud d'abord avec l'azerbaïdjan et la
turquie a une position particulière sur
la crise l'ukrainienne et elle l'avait
et elles continuent elles la maintenir
sur la crimée même s'ils ont bien tous
ceux que la question de la crimée résolu
définitivement mais elle fait des
déclarations la turquie fait délectation
sur le fait que l'annexion de la crimée
est inacceptable et cetera il y avait
notamment le président céline ce qui ne
l'a soutenue par les états unis qui a
fait de déclarations c'est sur la grille
mais il ya beaucoup de déclarations qui
sont faites
et permettant à leurs yeux de ne pas
respecter les accords de 8,6 en tout cas
des faisons allusion ou même ils ont
directement que la russie devrait
remplir un peu plus ses obligations 2
des accords de minsk et c'est écrit noir
sur blanc 2
alors que dans les accords justement
c'est écrit noir sur blanc qu'il doit y
avoir des discussions entre kiev le
grand dan s est donc le président
erdogan ce que s'est proposé comme
intermédiaire ici comme médiator le
kremlin par la voix de mes tripes eskov
a réalisé dix ans que nous sommes la
russie n'est pas partie au conflit et
nous observons simplement ce que fait la
la presse sur que sur les réactions
de notre presse secrétaire
porte-parole du kremlin il ya des
discussions qui sont faites directement
entre les présidents la spécificité tout
à fait positive de
entre nos pays c'est qu au niveau des
présidents de nos ministères et c'est
que justement sur malgré un certain
nombre de divergences
sur des problèmes importants de l'actuel
et internationale la discussion ce 2 sur
ces questions et la façon de gérer site
web se fait toujours dans un atmosphère
de camaraderie de respect mutuel c'est à
dire précisément comme nous estimons que
toutes les relations entre les pays
doivent se faire et notamment
en respectant justement l'ordre du
président émis hier précisément de façon
à avoir des garanties stable correct et
légales pour que la russie et c'est
voit ses frontières occidentales
respecter et contrairement aux pressions
que fait monter l'occident je le
remercie monsieur le ministre pour cette
réponse très détaillée très clair c'est
un certificat c de pl et je le remercie
madame atenco monsieur le ministre
pendant votre
ce que vous avez beaucoup parlé des le
cren mais je vais vous demander
votre banc de vue est ce que la
possibilité existe veut que la russie
prenne des sanctions contre le créneau
pour le non respect des accords de paix
nous sommes contre le système des
sanctions unilatérales
d'autant plus qu'ici les sanctions sont
pas unilatérale puisque
kiev a déjà prononcé des sanctions
contre des entreprises contre des
citoyens russes et notamment contre des
entreprises
qui n'ont aucun rapport avec le pib de
l'ukraine
mais au contraire actifs
ont un rôle très positif dans ses
relations donc ici l'évaluation qu'on
peut faire c'est que
faire des sanctions sans
sans se tirer une balle dans le pied
hors sas est une caractéristique du
régime de kiev nous avons pris les
mesures nécessaires
vis-à-vis des déclarations et des
porteurs de ressaut phobie qui se
manifeste ici un peu partout en ce qui
concerne les perspectives de respect des
accords de minsk nous essayons autant
que possible de parvenir et je pense que
le cren est un cas
perdu sûr si on prend si on considère
cette résolution du conseil sécurité de
l'onu vous avez entendu le président des
links qui au tout début de ces
de son mandat il avait dit que c'est
l'accord de mines ce qui est très
mauvais mais nous devons le respecter
voilà
pour
être quite vis-à-vis de la fédération
donc beaucoup de discussions durent les
premiers ministres des ministres
adjoints de la ministre des ministres de
la défense deux affaires étrangères de
ces forces unis
les accords de minsk sont vétustes sont
ont perdu de leur actualité c'est ce
qu'ils disent
le vice premier ministre qu'il
travaillait maintenant les ministres de
la défense et il a déclaré justement que
c'est un document politique qui peut pas
être considéré comme un document
juridique international
et alors là excusez moi mais la
résolution du conseil de sécurité et qui
dit que ces documents a vieillit qu'il
avait été pris par l'administration
précédente qui aujourd'hui il faut faire
intervenir les anglais les américains et
c est à ce moment là tout se passera
bien et donc il ya cette préparation
visant à l'aide à saper les accords de
mise donc des lois ont été adoptées sur
l'enseignement sur la langue nationale
etc au début la langue ukrainienne était
placé en priorité par rapport à toutes
les autres langues des minorités
nationales en ukraine mais maintenant
pour les langues de l'union européenne
une exception a été faite et donc le
russe s'est retrouvé tout seul dans
cette situation
alors que
est donc dans un magasin on peut s'en
prendre à quelqu'un qui s'exprimerait en
russe
si sa propre à l'avant 2 par exemple
donc aujourd'hui la question principale
c'est que
loi doit être
être adoptée sur la le statut de l'état
sa a été noté par le président et par la
chancelière merkel et le président macro
c'était 2 on a en gros une amnistie de
tout
d'une politique de lustration
d'épuration et de poursuite des
dirigeants des deux des deux régions qui
se sont autoproclamés république
populaire de votre donetsk est lougansk
et
l'inscription dans la constitution du
nouveau statut du donbass l'été creek
c'est que sans aucune élection il y aura
une administration civile et militaire
il était écrit que les forces armées
devront rétablir
l'intérêt de
l'intégrité territoriale du pays
sans accord avec les autorités sens
l'organisation
d'élections
et donc il y aura un contrôle sur
l'ensemble de la
de la frontière et donc ils vont imposer
une administration civile ou militaire
et qui permettra de béton reste est donc
une autre président comme j'ai déjà dit
à discuter avec merkel et macross leur a
posé cette question ils ont dit qu'il
ferait tout pour que cette loi ne soit
pas adoptée mais cependant je sais pas
est ce qu'ils ont parlé est-ce qu'ils
oubliaient de se parler mais le
processus le processus d'adoption de
cette loi se poursuit
et la commission de venise et le
parlement européen sont prêts
notamment dans la commission de venise
avait noté la position des représentants
russes
mais ils ont pas puissent en compte cet
argument
ils sont déclarés corriger ces aspects
et c'est bon et c'est tout
et donc nous ont été contraintes vous le
savez probablement de publier la les
échanges que nous avons eus avec nos
collègues allemands et français vous
avez vu que c'était des choses tout à
fait concrète qui ont été exposés sur le
papier ils se sont vexés
enfin il oriente y
est si depuis de longues années nous
promettent d'agir
d'influencé kiev pour renouveler dans la
réalité rien ne se produit et au
contraire kiev et se conduit de façon de
plus en plus éhontée vis-à-vis des à
cordes
minsk et vis-à-vis de la russie et
continue à provoquer les pays
occidentaux pour qu'ils soutiennent ses
humeurs belliqueuse alors comment
poursuivre ce travail dans ces
conditions quand on voit ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui
et quand on voit les promesses non
tenues de nos partenaires mais jamais
nous
n'allons ferme de crise et nous ne
considérons que c'est terminé c'est à
vous de le dire s'ils le veulent nous
continuerons à respecter nos accords je
remercie ministre lavrov sénateurs
dolgov s'il vous plaît je les remercie
madame atriale quoi qualité riche et
quelles sont les mesures prioritaires
que vous pouvez mentionné un qui seront
entreprises pour renforcer la composante
timonier terre de l'intégration
eurasiatique et notamment dans le
domaine de soutien de la langue russe de
la culture russe ce qui est aussi
important et vous en avez parlé
aujourd'hui pour la protection de notre
histoire commune dans les pays de
l'union heures à tiques comment
pouvons-nous contribué à vos efforts
reprises dans le cadre du ministère des
affaires étrangères ces dernières années
nous accordons une grande importance le
président et des différents d'eux
et madame atenco nous accordons une
grande importance à toute cette question
de création d'écolo russe pas seulement
en asie centrale en arménie aussi un
programme et nous avons fait beaucoup de
choses ici et bien entendu sur le plan
financier
on peut dire que c'est beaucoup moins
que ce que les pays occidentaux font
avec les british council et l'alliance
française les instituts goethe mais
nous avons l'institut pouchkine avec un
programme national du russey l'étranger
nous avons les programmes scolaires nous
avons un fonds
le fonds gores chaque of de soutien aux
compatriotes y est le fond du monde
russes et qui est financée largement par
l'état
et depuis un an et demi
après les changements au sein du
gouvernement et l'administration
présidentielle
sur la ligne de monsieur kozak
nous avons eu plusieurs réunions sur
cette thématique et nous avons décidé
justement de tous ces programmes de les
prendre pour les harmoniser
parce que certains travaillent de façon
parallèle et il ya des doublons donc le
gouvernement a validé un programme
unifié ici pour le développement
international et
déjà son coupé un certain nombre de
projets en matière de soutien de la
langue russe de soutien des compatriotes
à l'étranger ce programme actuellement
est considérée est consacrée uniquement
à la coordination mais nous espérons que
d'ici un an et demi deux ans il sera
complètement validé et étendu
notamment sur le plan financier et le
mystère de faire ce étrangères et comme
organe
directeur ici comme aux opérateurs
principe travaille justement ici à
résoudre un certain nombre de
difficultés qu'ils se posent elles sont
nombreuses puisque chaque service de
l'état à tel ou tel programme proposé
donc on comprend bien qu ici un travail
de coordination qui doit être fait ça se
comprend puisque il ya un système de
gestion ici à mettre en place mais
encore une fois la priorité c'est la
défense des intérêts de l'état remercie
sénateurs machine à bulles parole je le
remercie madame at il un coup violent à
gros budget représente
la région d'astrakhan les régions qui
contribuent au développement en est il
de la coopération internationale nous
avons une coopération étroite avec nos
partenaires de la région de la mer
caspienne
nous développons les échanges
commerciaux réalisons des projets
comment dans le domaine monétaire
économique et culturel une raison du
travail pour la création de plaster un
caspien ont composé de deux zones
particulières économique et portuaire au
tout cela nous prévoyons de créer en
kloster culturelles et éducatives de la
mer caspienne
évidemment l'activité du khédive avec le
soutien des régions est relié à la
compétence fédérale monsieur le ministre
vu les priorités de la politique
étrangère de l'est russie est ce que le
ministère
voit ce soutien des régions et prévoyez
vous
utilisez la situation géographique
particulière des différentes régions de
l'est russie notamment de la région
d'astrakhan ya pour contribuer à
renforcer la position de la russie dans
la région importante pour ses intérêts
puis bien sûr vous savez que sans les
régions c'est pas possible de mener un
travail aussi intensif de diplomatie
regardez toute discussion qui se fait
entre le président
et ses collègues à l'international où
les premiers ministres bien entendu il
ya toujours cette part importante qu'y
consacré aux entreprises aux régions
pardon et évidemment il ya les régions
de saint pétersbourg est de moscou
mais par exemple avec la chine il ya 99
région qui sont conseillés sur la
question de la mer caspienne séparé
depuis le premier jour de mon poste de
mon activité à ce poste j'étais
intéressé par cette question
la coopération des pays de la mer
caspienne
et ford
et astrakhan nous avons organisé
le sommet de la mer caspienne
et cette année
forum a été intéressant et nous avons
permis justement de définir la
convention sur le droit de la mer et
l'iran a demandé une pause et c'est seul
pays qui n'a pas signé mais nous
revenons justement à cette question
parce que la situation est différente et
notamment quand la convention entre rang
en vigueur donc les
les aspects politiques et
je dis qu signifie que les pays
prendront toutes leurs responsabilités
sur le rivage qui leur correspond et la
mer caspienne est interdite à tous les
pays autres
et ça veut dire que certains pays
occidentaux
manifesté un certain intérêt
de surtout l'espace post soviétique et
en particulier sur la mer caspienne
aujourd'hui après le sommet qui s'est
tenu au kazakhstan et qui a permis donc
la signature de cette
de cette convention nous préparons une
nouvelle discussion achkhabad et
peut-être sous forme de visioconférence
d'ailleurs il ya un projet qui est déjà
validé là dessus mais nous avons
évidemment
tous la préférence de pouvoir se
rencontrer directement c'est plus
efficace
pour discuter dans une atmosphère de
confiance les questions importantes et
parmi les initiatives qui vont être
proposées à ce nouveau sommet il y aura
la nôtre qui correspond à un conseil de
la mer caspienne qui sera installée à
astrakhan les détails sont encore en
cours de discussion personne n'est
contre cette initiative mais il ya
simplement certains certaines craintes
de certains pays il faisait peur que ce
soit une nouvelle structure politique je
pense qu'il s'agit
simplement de l'aspect pratique comment
organiser ça
est ce que ce sera un gros secrétariat
mais simplement il faut avoir des
réunions régulières pour pouvoir
discuter des différents aspects qui
concernent la mer caspienne pour que
ce soit pas simplement la préparation
d'un nouveau sommet mais que ce soit un
travail mené en permanence je vous
remercie madame helena clp monsieur le
ministre
pendant l'une des
réunions avec votre participation encore
le mans je vous ai adressées les
questions de ab marqué la région de la
frontière de la russie et du kazakhstan
à omsk c'est seulement avec votre aide
que ce problème à qui a traîné pendant
longtemps a été résolu je vous en
remercie hébergement et je vais vous
aiderez c'est encore une question vous
faire partager encore un problème qui
aggrave la situation
dans la coopération à cette étape nous
avons huit points des passages qui ont
été créés en
1998 et ne sont plus conformes aux
exigences modernes par rapport à aux
points de passage à la côte et kazakhe
qui sont vraiment moderne et ça ne fait
pas
ça ne fait pas plaisir de les visiter
nous avons plusieurs fois adressé des
demandes au gouvernement au ministère
des transports ministère des finances
pour l'heure deux pour leur demander de
résoudre la question pour le financement
de modernisation des points de passage
frontaliers
évidemment c'est pas tout à fait la
question du ministère des affaires
étrangères mais je m'adresse à vous
comme à quelqu'un qui n'a pas de petite
question que lorsqu'il s'agit des
intérêts de son pays ou du prestige de
la russie je vous demande de fret à
l'attention des ministères approprié
pour à l'actualité de ce problème je
vous ai adressé cette demande et d'après
la tradition je couperai de données en
papier
je remercie je tiens à préciser que les
questions qui concerne l'image de la
russie devant ses partenaires à
l'international et devant ses citoyens
ne peuvent pas ne pas être liés à
l'activité du ministre des affaires
étrangères est comme ça était notée par
les collègues qui est not to c
sous et je
travaillerai sur ces questions
ce n'est pas seulement sur cette portion
de la frontière que vous avez cités mais
aussi dans d'autres régions avec les
pays voisins donc on note
des demandes récurrentes juste justement
sur l'organisation de cela et nous
sommes très attentifs à cette question
je vous remercie ma famille tshibal à
vos paroles je vous remercie madame
attias
lavrov en ne retenant en entrevoyant
dessus de la république turque à
l'arrivée auprès de
l'irb hogan l'art public turquie se
positionne d'une façon active comme
étant le centre du monde turc le dernier
épisode lorsque
une carte a été offerte à erdogan où
tous les peuples turcs ont sont
mentionnés et notamment on y trouve des
régions de haute volta et d'altaï et
voir une étoile on
fixe la turquie comme étant le centre de
ce monde turc évidemment ça va provoquer
des émotions assez vivent parmi nous
nous connaissons tous ce que a les
ancêtres des peuples turquie
les racines se trouvent sur le
territoire russe est-ce que vous pouvez
nous donner le commentaire de cet
épisode pour parler de cette offensive
humanitaire pour le moment de l'est
républicain turc à l'espace de l'ex
union soviétique
j'ai déjà abordé ce thème quand je
répondais à votre collègue de l'altaï
donc
semachko fausse temps et l'altaï se
disputent cette question je ne sais pas
pour être sérieux je le vois rien de
problématique ici on peut maintenir des
contacts avec les compatriotes tous les
les congénères je sais pas quel terme à
utiliser ici à mon avis
si on considère l empire russe où
l'union soviétique donc nous aussi nous
pouvons
[Musique]
enrichir la carte du monde avec la
position de nos différents
compatriote un peu partout dans le monde
et évidemment donc c'est un très grand
nombre de compatriotes qui sont partout
qui représente les peuples de l'union
soviétique en allemagne dans d'autres
pays en israël aux états unis en
amérique latine en argentine même donc
évidemment on peut mettre toutes sortes
de couleurs sur la carte du monde mais
encore une fois nos partenaires turcs il
est vert donc un conseil de des langues
et sûrs qu'ils ont maintenant une
organisation
qui s'est réuni au kazakhstan et donc
cela avait été des cas mais nous nous
considérons cela comme normal ce genre
de manifestants s'il s'agit de processus
culturel de maintien des traditions
linguistique des échanges en matière de
d'enseignement cela me choque pas nous
mêmes nous devons faire la même chose de
façon plus efficace pour pouvoir quand
on parle de coopération universitaire
par exemple mais cela
il ya des cas
qui n'ont pas été détaillées qui n'ont
pas expliqué s'il ya des aspects de
coopération militaire évidemment cela
n'ira pas dans l'intérêt ni de la
turquie de ses partenaires de sur un
nouvel état turcophones ce que je veux
dire ici
d'ailleurs
les présidents vont parler entre eux et
moi je parlerai avec le ministre au show
blue demain à stockholm nous allons
parler nous discutons ouvertement de ces
questions et je ne vois là aucun rien de
suspicieux ici c'est normal d'avoir des
explications et
de demander des explications qui doivent
être nécessaires pour respecter
l'équilibré des intérêts en tout cas je
ne vois rien ici l'audacieux dans cette
politique de politique culturelle
dans ce temps qu'il s'agit bien des
changements culturels et non pas de
séchage et n'ont pas de fondement d'une
autre d'un autre type de coopération je
remercie sur collègues vous avez
beaucoup de questions alors je vous
demande d'être bref sénateur bert us
kids
merci monsieur le ministre la majeure
questions d'aujourd'hui c'est comment
arrêter les tendances de dégradation des
systèmes pré et relations
internationales
faire revenir à l'ordre du jour la
volonté à trouver dialogue qui en
cherchant des solutions
mais qu'il montre engagée comme vous le
savez pendant les moments de la guerre
froide à l'initiative de l'union
soviétique a été créée une réunion pour
la sécurité la coopération cette région
d helsinki avec la participation des
etats-unis du canada ce qui a permis de
à transformer les situations est ce
qu'on peut envisager le même approche
maintenant vous avez tout à fait raison
nous en parlons souvent parce que nos
partenaires occidentaux
ce n'est pas qu'ils ne peuvent pas c'est
qu'ils ne veulent pas discuter dans une
atmosphère de respect mutuel sur des
décisions qui soient acceptables pour
toutes pour tous et donc en matière de
sécurité cela est particulièrement clair
dans la discussion que nous aurons
demain à stockholm de haut niveau des
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'aude reste 6e il ya cette rhétorique
agressive à caractère homophobe donc
très souvent on va exiger de nous de
changer de politique évidemment nous
allons les appeler au dialogue mais il
ya des limites comme quand le président
nous a confié le 28 novembre au collège
d'une serre affaires étrangères de
défendre les intérêts de la russie qu il
a souligné et encore moi je les répéter
encore nous préférons le dialogue
à l'issue duquel des solutions
acceptables pour toutes seront prises
permettant d'assurer la sécurité
collective et cela concerne en premier
le losc et nous sommes prêts à cela mais
si nos partenaires occidentaux
ont perdu perdent peut-être pas
définitivement encore leur culture la
culture du dialogue de la recherche de
compromis à ce moment là
c'est une porte qui ne sera jamais
ouverte et j'espère que ce ne sera pas
le cas mais en entendant certains
orateurs occidentaux on a l'impression
que c'est ça quand même
je vous remercie à brice noeser of
mercy
c'est lavrov je le remercie pour votre
intervention détaillé pour vos réponses
très claires aux questions qui sont
posées et c'est d'autant plus sans
plaisir de vos et côté or lorsque vous
faites preuve de certains ironique et
d'amphores patriotisme en répondant aux
questions des journalistes étrangers je
vous en remercie ma question à pendant
deux mille vente et en plan comment
internationale visant à interdire
les trafics illégaux a été propre et en
russie le plan national d'action a été
adopté en 2013 et actuellement c'est
presque réalisé totalement pendant les
réunions du conseil
pour les questions de ressources
naturelles le 15 novembre de l'année en
cours nous avons étudié les questions de
soutien législatif des mesures visant à
interdire les
trafics illégaux
et les participants de ce qu'on sait on
remarquait la nécessité de
concevoir en nouveau plan national
nous avons au coopérer avec nos
partenaires étrangers est rangé dans le
cadre de conception de ce nouveau plan
national est-ce que vous soutenez à la
réalisation de consultations avec nos
partenaires étrangers pour interdire
toute sorte de l'artisanat et l'écho
quand nous avons deux rencontres nous
partons toujours de cela et recevoir en
exporte un petit peu aimé nos voisins
ont conclu des
accords là dessus
dans quelles zones sont effectués les
pêches
et dans le cadre de ces accords
nous avons une commission il ya un
dialogue qui est menée avec des raisons
qui ont aidé des discussions qui
nécessite une décision politique si
c'est nécessaire si les questions sont
relevés au niveau des ministères voir
plus haut mais nous sommes toujours
intéressés à ce que les résolutions
soient
respectés au niveau international et
bien entendu et nos pêcheurs eux aussi
nul n'est sans tache évident mais il
faut aussi être des exemples il faut au
niveau de l'état au niveau du
gouvernement de la façon que nous
respectons les accords internationaux
donc des recommandations sont faites
chaque année
pour montrer qui parmi nos partenaires
respectent ou demandes telles activités
mais je pense que une telle approche
permet justement d'offrir des solutions
je le remercie chers collègues je
propose de passer à la dernière question
si vous n'avez pas d'objection vu le
faute de temps s'il vous plaît à
recevoir
messieurs lavrov et l'été les dents que
cette intervention détail a été préparé
pendant longtemps alors je voudrais vous
poser la question sur la déclaration de
le cacher le président le coach enhco
qu'il a fait hier
en parlant de la possibilité de son
point de vue de faire en planter à
l'armagnac les russes sur le territoire
biélorusse se prévaut commenter cette
annonce
je dirais que cette déclaration était
une sorte d'avertissement prudent
fait
face à la politique souvent déraisonnée
des pays occidentaux si vous prenez
on a souvent le secrétaire général de
l'otan jens stoltenberg qui intervient
qui était l'ancien premier ministre
norvégien
qui soutenait un mode de discussion
normale or aujourd'hui je sais pas ce
qui lui est arrivé mais il se comporte
de façon extrêmement agressive et et
quand en allemagne une nouvelle
coalition se met en place aujourd'hui
elle est en place quand elle était en
processus de formation
il ya eu des fuites dans la presse qui
disait que certains membres de cette
coalition
se prononcer pour
qu'on
que les armes nucléaires soit extraite
du
territoire de l'allemagne et stoltenberg
avait dit avec si l'allemagne n'est pas
d'accord à ce moment-là nous déplacerons
ses armes un peu plus à l'est donc
des pays démocratiques
qu'est ce que ça vous signifie ce est ce
qu'il faut c'est ce qu'il faut expliquer
ici à nos partenaires occidentaux pour
qu'ils comprennent que ce type de ceux
comment dire
des raisons
cesse de se manifester donc il y à des
déclarations qui sont tout à fait
irresponsable et qui ne font que
renforcer
l'attention et qui peuvent être
provocatrice de conflit je sais pas ce
qu'ils cherchent et s'il mais je pense
que la sq est très important c'est que
si ils agissent s'ils manipulent des
idées autour de deux déplacements
d'armes nucléaires plus près de la
frontière de la fédération de russie
au mépris de l'acte ii qui avait été
signé entre la russie et l'otan
donc on a ici des contre exemples
de coopération ça montre ici quelque
chose de tout à fait négatifs je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre je
remercie pour les réponses très claires
intéressante et pour l'information
présentée lors de votre intervention
c'est de grande utilité pour nous et
nous allons le prendre en considération
pendant notre travail en coopération
parlementaire mettant de passons à des
interventions suivantes